what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and you're a little racist with that
bruce lee sweatshirt but that's fine
dude this is it's not it's not is that
for bobby no
i just really you know no you're not
chinese korean roots of fight
who i'm a big fan of sent a whole bunch
you saw those boxes i think this is an
unconscious thing on tom's part
no just to bruce lee if you had all the
other muhammad ali you had a
you think i should go change allen
iverson and and you picked out the bruce
i think it's a little i like
your conscious decision maybe because
you know that bobby's too lee's coming
here
yeah yeah is this should i change it no
no you're fine with it
i like it i think that i think you um
are trying to make me feel comfortable
and i think that that's like you're
going out of your way to make me feel
good
this is a perfect segue first of all i'm
not gonna forget that
uh meth gets your dick hard okay if
you've had any kind let's talk about
to disorder problems i'm here to tell
you forget that bag or forget about
salads forget about dick and
plants and all that stuff yeah so i
don't know if you believe me or not
yeah but if you like to see me smoke
smith with a small limp dick
that didn't get hard any other way and
watch it get harder and harder the more
i smoke
the harder my dick gets is that was that
your experience
yes wow you were 11. it doesn't matter
well let's talk
let's talk about the first time can we
talk about the fir how does one how does
one procure
math smoke at the first time how did it
happen okay here we go okay
yeah you want to go down memory line yes
i'll go down memory lanes
okay to you yeah number one
when i was in my late childhood am i
eight nine years old
when eight nine years old i was late
that's like yeah i was uh practically an
adult
i was molested okay what
no i'm yeah okay when you were when you
were
89 i was molested by a guy with down
syndrome i do it in my act
goodness are you serious okay and then
michael
is the guy i'm sorry i don't in his 20s
i'm over it [ __ ] man
it didn't bother me at the time i don't
think i don't really
find your story to be like a real
molestation i feel like it was like a
barter a trade system
because you kept going back to the same
guy yeah yeah you're right
well that's how they court you i mean i
i i understand
[Music]
i had my first threesome at 35
36 and it was one of the worst things of
my life yeah
two girls and one guy two girls you've
never done a threesome with two guys one
girl
no no i have a couple times i'm looking
at another guy
what is that comics i did it with mike
burton you know mike burton is no
mike burns is a stand-up yeah yeah he's
still around yeah yeah yeah yeah mike
burton
and a feature the girl i can't say her
name because she's still around
and we do the threesome and um he was so
selfish
because you know i mean he would pull
her up to his side of the bed
and i don't want to touch him so you
know what i ended up doing
going to the side of bed and just
masturbating watching them
and we also can i just say something we
all laughed
so much it was like the funnest sex i've
ever really ever had
you know and i did it with aaron cater
and brian etheridge once in vegas too
that three that was a five seven i was
gonna say that was a five something
i don't know where did you meet the two
girls
dude um this is so gross
so um you know what you know steve
saripa yeah so schrippa
riviera yeah so he calls me and goes
you know because dice used to call me
ching right so
so steve stripper used to call me ching
right as is
chi-ching that's what they used to say
not racial but i know it was racial
so you're like hey ching i go hey we're
doing this midnight dirty show i want
you to headline
i'd never headline before so brian
etheridge
and aaron cater were open micros at the
time did we'll drive you
i mean we'd love to see that right so
they drove me out there
so we're on las vegas boulevard these
two sisters
drive by right and brian atheros is
driving
and the two sisters roll down the window
and they go you're cute
not to brian because he's the ugliest
white dude i've ever seen or me
they were saying decatur kate is a
[ __ ] cute boy yeah good looking kid
right
cater runs out of the car jumps into
this [ __ ] truck
they drive out into the sunset right and
me and brian are [ __ ] mad
all right so then we get to the revere i
go brian you go do your own thing i have
to concentrate right on my set list or
whatever
so then midnight i'm literally on stage
and i see
brian and aaron bring in these two
sisters what was like a 300
pound white lit girl and the other one
was 80 pounds but they were sisters
and they were missing teeth but you know
at the time you know i need you know
so anyway after the show aaron goes hey
don't do us so let's go to the room
so we're in the room and so you know
you're
no condom either you know i know so we
were doing it you know doing it and
doing it and then all of a sudden like
three hours later
i'm with the fat one and aaron's with
this skinny one
i don't know what brian is i don't know
where brian is
so i look around the room i don't know
what brian is maybe he's in the bathroom
no he's not in the bathroom
so i keep doing i'm doing but doggy
style with this fat one
and i feel something tickling my
butthole it was like a feather
you know what i mean i turn around not
no one's there
so it was like paranormal you know what
i mean i thought it was like a
paranormal
ghost tickling your butt yeah yeah yeah
but then like i keep going and i find
and then i definitely feel something you
know like ob like something you know i
mean and i look down
brian had crawled underneath my body
and he was eating her [ __ ] while i'm
having sex with her now let me tell you
something let me tell you something
you have to imagine what is on his face
now at this point you know
my little goop juice he's got [ __ ] juice
fat juice you know what i mean mixed
together you know i mean
who knows what kind of you know why not
just go for the [ __ ] what does he
i don't know but he goes she likes it
she likes it i don't like it
because it's like his chin is rubbing
against my taint
i don't like it it's weird right i can't
get hard
so it gets worse so i decided to power
vlogger
right so i go you know how you're doing
taro
i'm not gonna get in trouble for the
same time power [ __ ] nobody in ten years
yeah that's right
like that you know what i mean and you
know i slipped out right
so i tried to stick it back in and but
brian had moved up right
and it rubbed against his eye right so
then we all disband you know i mean
because like he screamed you know what i
mean
and i go we gotta fight like why are you
down there you know me you purposely
i didn't purposely you know so then
afterwards we go to breakfast
so i'm taking these two girls off for
breakfast erin's there
and we're talking laughing i just can't
wait to go to sleep and i look at brian
from across the table
his left eye completely closed with a
yellow film
a yellow film had closed it shut like an
adhesive
right i go dude we got to go to the
[ __ ] hospital
because no i'm good i go no you're not
good you can't [ __ ] see out of the
eye
it's like infected it's red it's like
pulsing
you know which is his [ __ ] fall right
so then we go to the [ __ ] um
hospital right now we're no sleep you
know what i mean
it's a disaster right and we're i'm
in there with them you know i mean with
them we're like what are we gonna say
right he goes i'll just make something
up so the doctor goes what happened
and he goes he skull [ __ ] me he points
at me so
i skull [ __ ] them you kind of did
yeah but not you know did you have him
check your dick because like what what
was on your dick that made his eye close
up
dude it was not just my dick the jew all
kinds of stuff man you don't [ __ ]
listen dude
i can't believe my i just i went to the
doctor two weeks ago
and i got all tested oh my shit's clean
dog and i've done god's work
yeah right no gay yeah i mean just not
doing gay things shrimp
no shrimp no shrimp yeah no shrimps
leviticus yeah i've been uh i've been um
i try to give as much as i can you're a
giving guy yeah and i want to be
spiritual
you know so people can listen to me
right now and got me heathen
that's fine no they're not but you know
what one can
repent and one can change his behavior
why would you
feel bad though it's not your fault your
parents weren't on the
list let me tell you something my kid
doesn't take a dump for a day and i'm
all over him
if your parent doesn't know that you're
smoking meth and you're out in the
streets and you're doing stuff that's on
them man they should have had
an eye on you yeah it's not your
responsibility yeah
would you like how do you feel oh my god
you can't let it go can i go into what
i want to know first of all you i'm
bobby off the hook with the dick sucks
were you naturally good at it because i
feel like oh my god
i feel like i feel like yeah as a guy
you're like i know what i like so you
have like certain skills right
well that's silly i just want to say
this to you and i'm not going to go into
detail about it okay
but when you're young you don't know
what you like
yeah so i think it was pretty much
amateur hour okay
you know i mean i would probably like i
wouldn't go down to the sack or the
taint
yeah right and go you like that
right i think it was more like you know
licking the tip and going you know you
know is that suffice
right what it's just funny
make
a gay man yeah and i was and you were
gay and you and i were having sexual
sexualities with each other you and i
would probably be like um we probably
know what we
we liked you know of course and we would
do extra things
you know yeah to please ourselves sure
i would like to please you thanks yeah
you're welcome i like that but yeah he
was a kid babe
kids kids don't know how to give blow
jobs in case you're wondering
i mean were you blowing adults or
no no no no oh my god you can't let it
go again
it's just like i can't let it go again
and this is your fault sweetie do you
like that yeah yeah
it's your favorite oh my goodness so
check this out this guy
yeah smoked mess with his brother huh
something
cool happened my brother didn't believe
me but when he smoked with me he put out
his dick i couldn't believe how big his
dick was
he jacked off in four strokes and shot
the most [ __ ] he's ever shot
and he's fine he has no drop problems at
all yeah
his dick is even harder and thicker and
even more calm he
believes me now
this is a pretty good ad for meth i
think right yeah
yeah i mean there's no man that'll say
to you you know what i really don't
enjoy when a woman licks my [ __ ]
that guy you just walk you like you do
you like eating butthole i like eating
it i like my [ __ ] eating but who am i
gonna talk to eat my ass you know what
i'm saying
i gotta talk like a [ __ ] mule thing
in my head
like a mule or a cat they're like mine
it doesn't seem like a dirty ass it's
probably just a big butthole
it's disgusting anybody's [ __ ] is
disgusting yeah that's my whole point
that's why i am
delicious oh my god everybody's like
purple and like
bulbous mine looks like a black person's
foot it's painfully [ __ ]
it looks like it's stepped on a
firecracker like a black dude stepped on
a firecracker
mine's cute mine's cute it's like pink
and very tight
my poopoo looks like angel her pasta you
know it just comes out like a little
tiny noodles that's disgusting and i
know
that's just i was thinking about it no
but you know think of
if a guy walks out of his shell there's
no man in america if a woman drops to
her knees and says i want to lick your
ass i don't believe in that
yeah i think there's a lot of guys who
would say no to that let me lick it well
you first of all no woman's going to
tell you she's going to lick your ass
she's just going to stick her tongue in
there
and you're going to hit the [ __ ] your
eyeballs are going to hit the third eye
is that really what happens
like the first time your girlfriend
doesn't eat your butthole no no
look at me right now no no no no no why
not because i don't want her to
that's yeah that's on you oh but well i
don't that's on you and you gotta look
in the mirror and you have to question
yourself man
okay listen i'm a big good i'm a big
dude there's no way like
even after a shower like today i took a
shower and then immediately had to take
a [ __ ]
so i'm that's me it's never clean
but then how do you have a girl lick it
the thing is is that if they love you
they'll do it you know like i love my
girlfriend you know i've done it
you know and it's not you know there's
like a
a taste you know a residue
is it residue oh [ __ ] but no but you
don't know what [ __ ] yeah
but [ __ ] doesn't taste like [ __ ] it
smells like [ __ ] when you eat [ __ ] it
doesn't taste like [ __ ] really what does
it taste like
it tastes like food you ate it tastes
like this no it doesn't do it the night
before
it's only brown with the taste of
intestines
that same [ __ ] that steamed chicken corn
and blue you eat at night
tastes the same way in fact when you
taste it you'll say to yourself
[ __ ] it's a steak i eat it
intestine and grass
you